hey guys it's joanna here a lot of you
have been asking me what is my strength
training routine when i work out in the
gym so i work out in anytime fitness and
i'm going to share with you what i do on
a total body workout day let's get
started we want to work on the entire
body your legs back
chest triceps and also abs start by
performing each of the exercises for 15
to 20 repetitions and aim for three to
four sets with 30 to 60 seconds rest in
between
let's start by working on the biggest
muscle our legs white smith machine
squats this machine targets your glutes
inner thighs hamstrings and quads begin
by setting the bar to your shoulder
height and load the weight appropriate
to you
so start with 10 to 15 kilos on each
side
position yourself right in the center
with the bar rested on your shoulders
not your neck grip the bar firmly with
your palms facing forward
stand in a wide stance your knees and
toes pointed outwards
as you inhale bend your knees to lower
yourself until your thighs are parallel
to the floor in a slow and controlled
manner your back should be flat chest
open
your knees should not go over your toes
with your butt pushed back slightly the
weight should be on your heels not your
toes
exhale
push up through the heels to raise the
bar back to the starting position
do not push up by raising your shoulders
your upper body should remain stationary
with the movements coming only from your
legs
next leg workout walking lunges this is
a love-hate relationship it is not an
easy workout but it sure is effective to
work on the entire leg muscles your core
and also hip flexors
stand tall with your feet shoulder width
apart holding the dumbbells in your
hands
choose a weight that's between 4 to 8
kilos each
take a large step forward with one leg
and lower your body toward the floor
both legs should be bent at a 90 degree
angle at the bottom of the lunge as you
exhale drive through the heel of your
front foot to raise yourself back up and
immediately take a wide step forward
with a back leg it is very important to
make sure that you engage your core
throughout the exercise to keep your
back straight chest open and look
forward do not hunch lean forward sway
your body or look down keep the upper
torso as stationary as possible
now let's move on to work on our back
muscles
let pull down this machine works on your
lats or i like to call it your wings
hold the bar in a wide grip chest
upwards back slightly arched and feet
firmly on the floor as you exhale pull
the bar down towards your chest
squeeze your shoulder blades together
for one count and feel the contraction
on your lats
inhale and slowly release the bar back
to starting position
arms fully extended and lats are fully
stretched
repeat avoid swinging your body back and
forth the upper torso should remain
stationary and the movement should only
come from your forearms
seated cable row this workout focuses
more on the mid back muscles
sit and place your feet firmly on the
front platform keep your knees soft and
slightly bent hold the handles firmly
keeping your upper body in a neutral
position and elbows slightly bent
as you exhale
pull the handles toward your torso and
focus on squeezing your shoulder blades
together
your back should be slightly arched and
your chest should be sticking out
keep your elbows pointed back and close
to your body do not spread your elbows
out to the sides
squeeze your meat back muscles and hold
the contraction for one count and slowly
release back to starting position
and repeat
again avoid moving your entire body the
only movement should be from your arms
now let's work on the opposite muscles
which will be our chest
let's start with dumbbell fly this is a
great exercise not just to work on your
chest muscles but to also work on your
stability and mobility in your joints
lie down on a flat bench feet firmly on
the floor a dumbbell in each hand
directly above your chest pumps facing
each other you can start with three to
five kilos each
inhale and lower the dumbbells to the
sides in a slow and controlled manner
until about chest level
as you exhale squeeze and engage your
pecs together to bring the dumbbells
back up and rotate your wrist to face
you this rotation on the wrists will
help you to engage your chest muscles
even more
do not lock your elbows keep a slight
bend in your elbows throughout the
dumbbells should always be at chest
level not too high or not too low
the next chest exercise is my favorite
low cable crossover you don't have to
lift heavy at all for this workout start
with the lightest weight which is about
5 kilos each start with two pulleys set
at the bottom position grab the handles
and step forward until there's enough
tension in the pulleys your arms should
be at about a 30 degree angle from your
sides palms facing forward arms straight
with a slight bend at the elbows
as you exhale contract your upper chest
to pull your arms up and together until
they are at about shoulder level palms
facing up
inhale and slowly release to starting
position the movement should be coming
from your arms by engaging your chest
muscles your entire body should remain
as still as possible
let's move on and work on the smaller
muscles our triceps if regular tricep
dip doesn't challenge you enough try
doing it on the bar i love this workout
it makes me feel strong and toned
grip the bar handles with your palms
facing each other keep your legs
together and knees bent in a slow and
controlled manner lower your body into a
dip until your elbows are bent at a 90
degree angle
exhale engage your triceps to push
yourself back up and repeat
your elbows should be close to your
sides and pointed back do not spread
them open
engage your core to maintain an upright
torso and avoid swinging your body
forward or back you should feel your
triceps shoulders and also chest
and the final exercise is to work on
your core
full extension begin by lying on your
back with your arms extended overhead
and legs extended out i'm using a 5 kilo
weight to add more intensity as you
breathe out
curl up bringing your knees to the chest
as you lift your shoulders off the floor
bring the plate towards your ankles
breathe in extend your arms and legs
straight out back into starting position
and repeat do not use momentum to propel
yourself up
engage your core and control the
movements of your legs and arms
beginners you can't start without any
weights these are 8 total body exercises
i like to do in the gym to get a solid
strength training session so the next
time you hit the gym be sure to do these
exercises and follow the tips remember
proper form is extremely important to
target and work on the right muscles
start with a weight you're comfortable
with and as you progress challenge
yourself by lifting heavier go with more
reps and reduce your rest time do these
exercises at least two to three times
weekly and you can combine it with my
other heat workout or cardio videos
right here don't forget to like this
video share this video on and hit the
subscribe button if you haven't yet done
it for a lot more workout videos fitness
tips nutritional tips and healthy and
delicious recipes all the best